a country devastated two months after
unprecedented Monsoon rains caused a lot
of damage across much of Pakistan roads
homes and businesses remain underwater
in some areas
July's floods affected 33 million people
across the country more than 1 700
people died but for those who survived
it's been an absolute struggle
thousands of people are living in
makeshift camps with no health
facilities and there's a lack of clean
water and food
since we arrived in these tents we
haven't received much from the
government we don't know where the aid
is going we barely get food once a day
and if we do it's a fight everyone is
pushing each other to get just one piece
of bread to survive
the national nutrition survey says 1.6
million children are in need of urgent
treatment for acute malnutrition
especially in the worst affected areas
of sindhan baluchistan and the United
Nations reports that more than 6 million
people no longer have clean sanitation
or toilet facilities
waterborne illnesses skin conditions and
respiratory infections are spreading
fast
we are now homeless and in the middle of
nowhere our houses were Swept Away
diseases have attacked us because we're
all standing in the water every child
woman young and old person I know is
suffering from either diarrhea malaria
or stomach problems and there's no
medical care
Pakistan's government says it's run out
of money and it's desperately appealing
for help it's trying to secure loans but
there seems to be donor fatigue earlier
this month the UN revised its aid appeal
from 160 million dollars to
816. UNICEF says it's only received 13
of the money it's trying to raise
the historic flooding caused around 40
billion dollars in Damages cash trap
Pakistan was already facing a serious
financial crisis before the heavy
Monsoon rains and it hopes it can raise
more money at next month's un climate
conference in Egypt
Al Jazeera